(gentle music)
- Welcome for another episode
of the "Addy Hour" this week,
I'm really excited about our
conversation about mental,
physical, and spiritual
health with Dr. R. Kweku Smith
and Pastor Shino Prater.
And in a lot of ways
this really encapsulates
what we are about on this podcast,
really thinking about
all aspects of our health
and trying to think about
things in a holistic
and integrated manner.
So both these gentlemen,
I'm really excited to
have them on the podcast
because of who they are and
because both them really
epitomize this in their
investment in the community
in so many different ways.
So our first guest I'd like
to introduce to everyone
is Shino Prater, who I
know is Pastor Shino.
Pastor Shino is married
to Anne Marie Prater,
and also the father of three children.
He's a former football standout
who played his college ball at Penn State.
He also played in the NFL
for the Tennessee Titans
and played in the Canadian Football League
for the Hamilton Tiger, the Tiger Cats.
So obviously he had a lot of
success on the football field
and was able to make an
impact in that sphere.
But even while he was
playing professional ball,
also really invested in communities
in a lot of different ways.
Something that I know is
near and dear to his heart
and something that lots of people
are appreciative to him for.
Right now he's an associate pastor
at Every Nation Church in New York City.
He's also an assistant
chaplain for the New York Jets,
and he's formerly served as a youth pastor
and the campus pastor.
So again, someone who's really
been invested in communities
in a lot of different ways,
and I know someone who's
invested in whole health
and wholeness for our community.
So definitely grateful
to welcome Pastor Shino
to the program today,
thanks for being here.
- Thank you for having me, it's an honor.
Our next guest is Dr. R. Kweku Smith,
who is the president and CEO
of Black Hugh Smith Psychological
Consultative Services.
Dr. Smith earned his degree,
his PhD in urban education
with an emphasis in school psychology.
And he's someone throughout his career
who's also really just invested
in so many different communities.
So just to highlight a few,
he has experience in working and teaching
in the public school system,
both the elementary school
level and the high school level.
He's also been involved in
several other aspects as well.
He's worked in the Trauma Center
at the Children's Hospital of Wisconsin,
and has also been involved
Department Of Corrections,
working both with male
and female offenders.
And he's also worked in organizations
on topics like workplace
performance, diversity, inclusion,
and mental health.
He's previously served as a psychologist
for the Milwaukee Bucks.
Definitely, we have to give
a shout out to the Bucks
with the way they're
playing in the playoffs,
with their deep runs so far.
But he's also been involved
with the NFL as well,
working with lots of different NFL teams.
He serves on the clinical
advisory team as well.
And again, someone who is
an activist in many ways,
and really deeply
invested in the community
around all aspects related to
mental health and wellness.
So grateful to be able to
welcome Dr. Kweku Smith
to the program today,
thanks for being here.
- And thanks for having
me, it's an absolute honor.
- Well, again, I'm
grateful to both of you.
It's definitely a mutual honor.
I'm just so grateful for
the work that you've done
and for your willingness to share
some of that work with our listeners,
even as we are in this state
of emerging from the pandemic.
And then as our listeners
know, as my listeners know,
we often just like to check in with people
and see where they are.
Sometimes people I know can
feel like it's burdensome
to continue to talk about those things,
but I think it's important for
us just to be real and honest
with how we're all doing
on a day-to-day basis.
So Dr. Smith, if we could start with you,
if you'd just be willing
to give us a little bit
of how you're doing these days,
as we all are working through these things
as a community together.
- Yeah, so making sure I
understand your question right,
just how am I doing
personally during these days?
How am I navigating
during the COVID season?
And I think that's an excellent question
because there's always a question to say,
who helps the helpers?
Sometimes you're so busy giving.
And I know as a pastor,
when I look at Pastor Shino,
I'm thinking, wow, what he has
to give to his congregation
on a daily basis and how
that's amplified here.
And though I would never
equate myself to like a pastor,
being in a helping circle,
you are one who are
continually in this vessel.
You're pouring out,
and so the other sort of
question is how do I remain
feel so I can make sure
I can give to others?
And the honest truth,
this has been some highs
and there's been some lows.
I think there's a natural reciprocity
of refilling your cup by giving to others.
This that when I help
someone else it's a natural
either from a biological
neurological standpoint,
we talk about serotonin
and dopamine levels,
those things being increased
when you do something good.
But on a more like just intrinsic level,
I think when we do something good
just in our heart it helps us.
But then it becomes that tipping point
where you're giving and you're
giving and you're giving
and until where you're exhausted.
And what I'll tell you is what's been
one of the most difficult things for me,
is to make sure that not
only do I do well at work,
but what suffered the most was my home.
I could go to work and I
could get some things done.
Well, when I was going
home, I was finding myself,
giving my wife, giving my
children the absolute worst.
You know, I'm tired physically,
I'm tired emotionally,
quicker to snap and things of that nature.
And so when you look
in the mirror and say,
wow, if I'm helping other
people, if I'm giving strategies,
and if I can't employ these,
maybe they're not working
or why aren't I'm doing
what I'm actually giving
other people's to do.
And so to that point, what I decided to do
was to make a conscious
effort, being very intentional
about what was I going to
do at the start in my day.
And that the start of my day,
I was gonna give honor to my creator,
give honor to the ancestors,
those who laid the path.
But then the next was those people
who were right in front of me.
How was I gonna be a better dad?
How was I gonna be a better husband?
So asking questions.
And this was probably the most humbling,
but the best thing I could've done.
I asked my daughter, I said,
"Write me out a list of five things
that you would like for
me to improve upon."
And, oh, she she's 10 at the time.
And she was like,
"Well, maybe you can not
compare us to other people,
but maybe you can not holler us,
but maybe you could be
home a little more."
And you see things and it's very humbling,
but I was so happy that
she could be honest.
And so what did I do?
I started to make sure that
I was gonna spend more time.
I was gonna be more conscious
about how I spoke to my family,
I was gonna do those things.
And in that made me feel
a lot better, Dr. Addy,
because then what I started to see
is the things I was
telling other people to do,
if I implemented myself,
these things really work.
So we're getting more confident in it,
but it was only because of these falls
that I was able to be able to see it.
But it was being humbled
enough to hear it,
then being brave enough to ask for help
and then being courageous enough
to try to seek out different things.
And so we did some of those things,
we started building in our
house, we started doing projects,
things that gave us a purpose.
We bought some puppies, I
don't advise you buy two.
I kind of went overboard with that,
but what we wanted to do
though in this concept,
is it's to say, what can
we do to inject love,
to inject something different,
because we are being infused
with something different
from a negative standpoint,
so how could we counter that?
And through that time point,
there's still some ebbs and flows,
but what I've recognized
is it's a daily struggle.
And what I have to do is look
at myself on a daily basis
and say, what were my goals for the day?
It didn't at the end of
that day, start to evaluate,
did I accomplish these things?
If so, why did I, if not, why didn't I?
And if I didn't, what are the
things I can do to do better?
So even as we go through it,
I think it's still not a
thing that's in process.
It's a very fluid situation.
So as you talk about what did we do?
I would say, what am I
doing to try to make sure
that I don't go too far below again,
to try to stay even keel
so I can be good at home,
in the community and
then also with myself?
- Mm, that's so good, that's so good.
And I appreciate that level of
honesty and just the bravery,
I think in your self-reflection too.
The fact that you asked
your 10 year old daughter,
I think that takes some bravery
because you're gonna get an honest answer.
(all laughing)
You obviously did.
And just being willing
to take that step too,
because I think I've heard
people say those things
individually too, like,
oh, wow, I feel like I'm on thin ice.
I'm snapping a lot quicker than I used to.
And just to be able to
have that self-reflection
take a step back and then be
willing to let your daughter
take that step and to walk with her,
and I think that goes such a long way.
I think there's a lot that
we can all pull from that.
So appreciate you sharing
with that level of honesty.
I also love to know the
fact that you're applying
what you preach too.
I think that's easy for us,
I'd like Pastor Shino jumping in too,
but for us who are in
the business of healing
in any sort of type of
way, that sometimes it can,
I know personally it can be harder
to kind of incorporate
that in my own life.
Even if I'm telling my students that,
even if I'm giving talks and
sharing that with others,
but when it really comes down
to walking through it yourself.
So I appreciate you sharing
that journey with us as well.
- Yeah, Pastor Shino, what about you?
- So for me, I mean,
I have to echo everything the doctor said,
is because it is hard to give
when you're not receiving.
And so I had to early on
make just a mental note
that this is a marathon and not a sprint.
And I had to pace myself
because it was so much coming at me.
You know, phone, my phone
rang and it was nothing good.
It was nothing good.
And so it was, I got
this, contracted COVID,
such and such is in the
hospital, they may not make it.
So it was a lot of just
stuff coming at you.
People losing jobs, people
moving, we had to pivot,
because of what was going on,
the church wasn't meeting,
so we had to go online.
So it was a lot of stuff
to try to mobilize people.
And not only people like your congregation
and keep them full of faith
and keep them pointed towards
the Lord and lean in to Him.
But just like doctor said, I
had to take care of my home.
And so one of the things that I had to do,
was I had to make sure
before I did anything,
is check in with my wife and
checking with my children
because my oldest, she was
a way she was in college.
It was her senior year.
And of course, you know, she's just sad
because, "Hey, this is my last year,
this is how it's going to go down."
And they were half and half in school.
And so I'm trying to
encourage my 22 year old,
"Don't quit, don't give
up, you made it this far,
you're gonna graduate."
Then my middle daughter, she
enrolled in college in the city
and they're not having college.
So her first year was online.
So she's upset, you know,
"Dad, why's this going on?
You know, this is my
first year of college."
So she's going through it.
And my son being 17 years
old, wanting to play sports
and not being able to see his friends.
And so that was a difficult time.
And so just like Doc
was saying, it was like,
man, I can't be out there
trying to save the world
and I'm not taking care of my own home,
I'm not taking care of my space.
And so to check myself, I had to make sure
that I was putting in as
much as I could put in
by reading my scriptures,
reading the Word of God,
spending time with the Lord.
Not only that, but listening to podcasts.
Being able to not take a call
every time something came in,
because some of these calls
that were coming in were so taxing.
You wanna run to help, but
man, you can't do anything,
you can't do what you need to do.
You know, spending time
with you, Doc, Dr. Addy,
listening and to other doctors.
And that was important
because doctors were saying,
you need to rest, you need to hydrate,
you need to disconnect.
You know, as a pastor,
you wanna think you can
save the world sometimes,
but you know, you gotta understand,
you gotta give stuff to over to God.
You gotta give it to the Lord
and do the practical things
and take care of yourself.
The other thing was
rest, sleep is important
because if you're not careful,
you can go deep into
the night doing stuff.
You you don't have any margins,
meetings going into 10:00, 11:00 o'clock
at night with people up on the phone,
and just having to do those things.
And so for me, it was just slowing down
and saying look one day at a time
and rejoicing at every victory,
because there's something
about stopping and rejoicing
about the littlest things,
some of the smallest things,
bringing hope, bringing life into my home.
And we celebrated that as a family
and I wanted my kids to
get in on that as well
because I wanted them to see
that there were better days ahead.
And a lot of times we
overlook the littlest things.
And I think for me, waking
up in the morning was like,
I'm gonna thank the Lord for that
because there were some
people that didn't wake up.
Thank God that I still got a house,
that I still got food on my
table, clothes on my back,
just going through.
And I began to tell everybody in my home,
you need to identify and start
thanking God for everything.
There's anything you can think of,
because that's gonna bring
you hope that He's here
and He's gonna keep us moving forward.
So just like Doc said, there
were some dark moments,
doing funerals on Zoom
and not being able to weep
and cry with the people
when they're going through things
because of the isolation and
the separation, it was tough.
But the one thing that really I can say
that helped get me through was community.
Just talking to people,
praying with people,
crying with people,
this being in community,
the best that we could,
even though with a physical
community at the time,
it was just the moments
of just being online
and seeing someone's face.
And for me, I'm wired a little different,
I think doc said it as
well, I like to help people.
And so I went and we have
other churches around the world
and I got other pastor friends
that were going through it
way worse than we were,
prior to what was going
on here in New York.
And I remember man, just saying,
"How can I stand with you,
what can I do for you
during this dark moment?"
Because it was bad over
in Europe at the time.
And he was just saying, you
know, "Just pray with me, man,
cry with me, just stand,
let me talk as much as I can
about what's going on in my home
and with my wife and my children,
because I feel like
I'm alone over a here."
And man, it was just a good moment
to see him get through it.
And then he was with in our
dark moment as well over here.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well, appreciate it, definitely
appreciate you sharing
so honestly and powerfully as well.
I mean, just so many similar themes
for the two of you as well.
Just that balance between
the importance of giving
and how that's good for us,
but then also knowing the balance
between taking time to step back
and make sure that we're still
present with our families,
making sure that we're
still present for ourselves
and taking care of our
own health and balance.
And sleep is one of the things
we'll be talking about
in a future podcast,
just the effects of sleep on
mental health and vice versa.
So I think that's so important
that you brought that up as well,
but so many themes that cut across
what you both talked about,
just the importance of community
and the importance of serving,
and also the importance of perspective.
Pastor Shino you talked
about just having people
be thankful daily about the little things,
and I'm sure Dr. Smith, you
could talk about the effects
that it has for us
psychologically and on our brains.
So I think there's so many topics
that we're highlighting here
that I think are critical.
And I'm curious for both
of you, two-part question
in the sense of how the
people in your communities
have been doing and what advice
you've been trying to give
people in the communities
where you work to really move through
and to get to a place
of healing and wholeness
in the midst of everything
we've been facing as a society.
So Dr. Smith, if you wanna
jump in with that question
or those questions.
- Yeah. So I'm kind of like in the middle
of two communities.
So I do a lot of work with
the Wisconsin Badgers.
So I'm working with student
athletes in Madison, Wisconsin,
but I'm based in Milwaukee, Wisconsin,
which parental leave
for the last five years
have been either in the
top five, two or three,
unfortunately is the worst
place for a black male to live.
So those are two completely
different populations.
So working with a student
athlete population
where troubles are significant,
it's completely different
than what I'm dealing with in the city.
So and working with the
student athletes you say,
"Hey, how do I navigate
you being an athlete
at a Power Five Conference
with all of the pressure
that goes along with that?
Now with the different
disadvantages that COVID bring,
as it relates to our schedule,
that the bubbles it has created,
decided at different pressures
and still being a student.
And then just other things
that come with regular college life,
those issues that they have,
sometimes we see a small problems,
but those who are going through it,
is absolutely monumental
and trauma comes in different
forms in different fashion.
So what I try to teach them
and even to the second community
which I'll speak on next,
is how do we maximize the moment of now?
When we think about the past,
we're thinking about depression.
When we think about the future,
we're thinking about anxiety.
So those things are going
to come, but we'll say,
how can I control the
moment that I'm in now?
Because the things that's
happened in the past,
those things have hurt me,
but I can't change them.
My thing is how do I try to equip myself
to be able to deal with them
no matter how difficult,
they are understanding that
I can get through whatever.
And as it relates to that
anxiety for the future saying,
how do I not let that fear
of what's going to happen?
That may not even manifest
paralyze me from doing things now
that could actually benefit
me from what's going on.
Now in Dillon, in Milwaukee, where I'm at,
where I think we ranked like either worse
or next to work on
every social determinate
in the United States, from
the cradle to the graze.
Talking about premature
birth rate, low birth rate,
education, suspensions,
detention, unemployment,
under employment, health, STIs,
all the way to being in
the most incarcerated state
in the United States.
And then on top of that,
having a higher death rate.
So when we look at these things, you say,
well, how do I work with people
who are dealing with COVID,
who are dealing with systemic racism,
who are dealing with things
where they have literal problems.
Now, how am I going to eat?
My mom is in jail, my dad is dead.
Like, well, we have
these different problems.
It's a little bit different of
a focus on what can you say?
So we're still goes back
to what can I do now?
What can I control?
And what we have to do is
to be able to instill a hope
and a level of empowerment
inside of people to understand,
no matter how horrific our
tragic seemingly our situation,
that something beautiful
can still come from it
if we don't give up, if we keep pushing.
No matter how desperate it may seem,
no matter how dark it may be at the time,
it's about how do we create that hope?
And then going back to what you say,
even in the midst of some of that trauma,
what are some of the
blessings that was there,
what were some of the ways
in which we could have been
caught in and that we weren't,
which gives us a light to
know that there is a reason,
there is a purpose for our being.
And maybe we are going to be the spark
that makes it a lot
better for other people
who had to come the way we are coming up
or we'll come up that way.
So when you say like, what
population are you dealing with?
It's so many different avenues you go,
depending on who you're talking to.
So when you're dealing with
people who their issues
are kind of like, seemingly not trauma,
but it is trauma to them,
you give them that hope
as far as where they're
going, what they can do.
But when you're dealing with
people who are in the midst,
I mean, in the throes of
heartache, of pain, of frustration,
of not understanding where
our next meal might come,
or from being homeless at the moment,
what we have to do is really
focus on the moment and now,
and then address some of
those specific needs to say,
it's not just words, but also actions
that's gonna allow you to
know somebody to help you.
And that there are some resources
that you didn't even know.
And in those ways that you can't help,
it's like what pastor said before.
Sometimes it'd be an ear
and a shoulder to say,
the whole world is not cold.
Somebody who may be can't
do anything, but will care,
will cry, will share this time
and space of pain with you.
- Well, that's so powerful and
showing up in so many ways,
it seems like you're talking
about too, just being there.
How do people receive that?
'Cause I know there's a whole range
of how people would receive
that, whether they push back
or you don't understand my situation,
or I'm glad you're here,
how has that component come into play?
- Yeah, it always boils
down to, can you help me?
And if you can help me,
then obviously it's received
in a little bit different fashion.
If you're only giving words and no action,
then that gets tired after a while.
So what you have to do is
say, what Pastor said before,
we can't do it all, so how are
you connected with resources?
So even if I can't get you here,
can I get you connected to somebody?
Can I lead you to a way to
say, I know there's some help.
If I know there's no food on the table,
can we bring some food on
that table literally today
and then show you a
way to get it tomorrow?
So you say, how is it received?
How is it accepted?
There's always gonna
be some good, some bad,
but mostly in the middle.
It comes to the point
where I am appreciative
that you did what you said, took the time,
did show the care and did
point me into some directions
or did actually give me
some things that I needed.
That again, gives me back
to that level of hope.
Because once you have hope,
you remove the desperation
because when desperation comes in,
that's when we usually tend to see
the worst of the human being,
and that's what we wanna try to avoid.
- Yeah, it's so good, it's so powerful.
Pastor Shino, what about you
on some of those topics too?
'Cause you alluded to that,
just with all the calls
you were getting with them,
the devastation, a lot of similar ways
while the topics may have been different,
people were suffering
at the end of the day.
So how did you reach in and intervene
and try and do that in a way
that doesn't spread you
too thin at the same time.
- For us, it was just networking
and taking the resources that
we had and stretching them out
and getting them to the people
that needed it the most.
And so when COVID hit, first of all,
we're in a multi-ethnic church.
So being a man of color
in a multi at the church,
it was some tough days.
It was some times where
we had to navigate.
And it was just like, man,
conversations coming up,
whether it was through the political times
or the social injustice times,
or it was the economy times,
everything was just like, you
had to be on your Ps and Qs
because if you said the wrong
thing at the wrong time,
somebody could take it the wrong way
and start pointing fingers
and it just got ugly.
And so we really needed
to be able to navigate.
And so for our doctors, for instance,
they were running out of masks
and in different hospitals,
but we have family, church
family, and people over in China
that were able to come up with masks
and get those masks
from China over the us.
And this is where people of wealth
and means in our church
community were like, look, man,
just I'll pay for it,
I'll take care of it.
Let us be a blessing to our
doctors, our essential workers.
Just like Dr. Smith was saying,
not just talk, but action.
You know, hey, we struggling over here,
we're the front liners, we're
taking care of this community
and some of our own people.
So let us be, let's not just,
you know, what can we do?
We may not be able to
physically come together,
but what can we do?
How can we get resources
and things to people?
And that made a major
impact for a lot of doctors.
Doctors to this day, write
our pastors in our church,
and just say, "Thank
you guys for stepping up
and helping us because we
couldn't wear the same mask."
They were running out a masks.
And so just by the grace of God,
we were able to get
something to these doctors
in different parts.
We're talking Long Island,
we're talking the Bronx,
we're talking just different hospitals,
spread out through the tri-state region.
We're being able to get taken
care of during that time.
So that was life giving.
That was, man, we're doing something
in the midst of one of our darkest moments
and hours of our time
here in the States and around the world.
So being able to do something like that,
really was a blessing.
Other thing that I thought was important
was during the social injustice times,
it was important for us to
have hard conversations.
Now, even though you may not
be the color that I may be,
and you may not understand how I feel
and what I'm going
through during this time,
it's important that people
were willing to learn.
They wanted to know, I mean,
I get it but I need to know.
They were educating themselves,
they're reading books,
they're coming to meetings.
They're allowing people to
say what needed to be said,
having uncomfortable conversations.
I mean, conversations that
would make you cringe,
but they're not just
listening, but they're saying,
now, what can we do, how
can we be a part of this?
So help facilitating those moments,
participating in those moments,
being candid in those
moments was very important
for a lot of people in our communities.
We're talking about the community
of just being in a multi-ethnic community
was very important,
but being in a multiethnic
church was important as well,
bringing people out to march and to talk
and people that don't look
like you hand-in-hand,
arm-in-arm brought something.
It shows people stuff
that we may disagree,
but we still love each other.
And the most powerful thing
right now during this time
was that I was preaching love,
and not just preaching it,
but demonstrating it
'cause love is action.
Love isn't just talk, love is action.
I got to get out here and
I gotta be with the people.
I got to do stuff with the people.
And so it's hard to have people follow you
if you're not leading, if
you're not leading in that way.
So a lot of people are like, all right,
if you're gonna be out
there, we coming out there,
you know, and we're gonna do these things.
Another thing that was important
for me with the community
was being a sounding
board to police officers.
Now I notice it's gonna
sound awkward or strange,
but as a pastor, I had to get
out there with other people
and hear their story and being able to go
and I was able to talk
to 150 police officers
from all over the country.
These are some current and some former
and letting them know, I hear
you, I understand your pain,
I know what you're going through.
Yes, you're a father,
yes, you're a husband,
I mean, yes, you're a grandfather.
Yes, all that, you know,
you're a human being,
put it that way.
And putting myself out there and saying,
"Thank you for protecting our communities
and all this stuff that needed to do."
It cut across the
granite society, it hurt.
Matter of fact, some people
weren't happy about it.
But once again, as a man of God,
I had to step out and do
some uncomfortable things
to show somebody something.
Because at the end of
the day, what I realized,
just where we are today, 2021 of June,
you look, things have lifted,
things are going back to normal.
And so I was able to build
some bridges with some people
during those difficult times,
now they're calling this in.
As things are being restored,
things are being repaired,
relationships, friendships,
things are starting to be repaired.
I thank God, I was able to
build a bridge back then
when the storm was happening,
instead of trying to build a bridge now.
Now I have a little relational equity.
And I think that what's important
is having a relational
equity during dark moments,
during dark times, you were
there with me at the bottom.
And now that we're starting
to rise up out of the top,
we can build together,
we can do some greater things
together in our communities.
- Mm that's so good, and
again, that theme of community,
that's kind of across what
you're both talking about.
Just really meeting
people where they're at,
being there, sincerely
being there with action.
I think that goes such a long way
and I'm encouraged to just
see how things move forward
with those bridges being built.
I mean, especially as we
talk about mental health
and just people's awareness
of those types of things,
the challenge that we face.
And I think even the way
that you both shared your stories about,
personally, I didn't
take that time to rest.
I know for me, with my students,
I had to share those stories, honestly.
And there's something
different about as healers,
if we share that ourselves,
it seems like it takes it
to a whole another level
that people can actually
relate to grasp it,
rather than if we just talk about it
in a kind of abstract way, or
this is what you need to do,
but don't bring ourselves
into that conversation.
So I'm grateful for the ways
that both of you had done that.
So powerfully in so many different ways.
And I'm also curious how you
see things moving forward,
because it seems like at
least in a lot of ways,
everything we've gone
through is shaken us up,
woken us up to a lot of things,
but I'm hopeful that it's also woken us up
to just the importance of
emotional wellness too.
Do you think people are catching that
or do you feel like that's something
that's kind of momentary and passing?
If people are catching it, are there ways
that you're trying to make
sure that continues for,
and that people really pay
attention to those components?
So I think in both of what you're doing,
that that's an essential piece.
- Yeah, I think their more,
I'll let you go first Pastor.
And so, no, I think it's a point.
I look at January 1st, what
happens with everybody?
That's the day of what
resolution, we're gonna do it,
we're gonna go here.
So it's always, I think
something innate in us
to wanna restart, to be
better, to improve ourselves.
I think there's some
things that happen then
that starts to accelerate that clock.
You go into the doctor and they say,
oh, you have diabetes, you
have to change your diet.
That will force you to eat differently.
So sometimes it's from negative things,
sometimes it's like, you see
somebody else do something,
where you'd be like,
that's what I wanna do
in a proactive manner.
Now, when we get something
like COVID, you have to say,
it brings out the best
and the worst of us,
because whenever we're in this
type of situation, it does.
So some people have recognized
that, wow, you know what?
During this time I had
more time to now work out
to be able to eat different
'cause I wasn't going out as much.
I can do A, I can do B, I can do C,
which was all constructive.
But on the other end,
now you have some people
we call it the COVID-19
for another reason,
'cause those 19 piles are put on.
I am a little depressed, I
am not able to sleep right
and these are some things
that contribute to it.
But now from the emotional standpoint,
when we look at the lack of socialization
as so many people had, moving
from face-to-face interaction,
moving to the point
where we had six feet
of separation literally,
but what that meant to us emotionally.
So now the question
becomes, how do we recover?
When a person goes into a military,
if you've ever seen like
an 18 year old young man
going into the military, young, immature.
Right after bootcamp, it
looks like a different person
because there's been a training,
it's something intense.
And so what happened is
when we went into COVID,
we were all forced to go
under a boot training,
a boot camp in a different way
and we learned some things.
But now this is the key,
just like a person
who's returning from war
needs to be retaught, to be
reintegrated into society,
to make sure that the things
that was happening at war,
they can remove that
and then reintegrate
naturally back into society.
That's what's going on
with so many of us here,
and this is where the
emotional wellness come.
What will we do to now,
to what rewind our minds,
to go back to that old sense of normal
that we're going into, that
we haven't been in for awhile.
What will we do?
So it's gonna be about how
assertive the person it is.
And then that depends on what
are some of the situations
that we're going through
because let's be honest,
the brighter your outlooks, Pastor said,
people were losing jobs,
people were losing houses,
was harder to have emotional wellness
and to take care of some of those things
if you have those pressing needs
from a Maslow's hierarchy of needs
situation going on theory or not.
But when things aren't going good,
you do have those basic needs.
That's the time where you can say,
I do have the emotional wherewithal
to really try to like
take good care of myself,
to be able to do those things.
So I think what we have
to do is to look at people
individual situations,
but then also look at
some of those past traumas
that could have been re-triggered
from the COVID and say,
how do we properly reintegrate
everybody back into society?
So for every parent, for
every school teacher,
for every employer,
we're telling them to take a
different look at the people
who are coming back because everybody
is coming on different levels.
And if we try to do a
cookie-cutter approach,
we're gonna lose so many
people in so many ways
and it's gonna deteriorate.
But if we can catch
people where they're at,
that emotional wellness,
then we can help them
escalate slowly at a pace
that's gonna be helpful and beneficial,
not only for them, but for
the community at large.
- Yeah, I think that was so good.
And actually I have a question on that,
'cause I know sometimes when
I'm trying to advise people
and things like that,
people are feeling surprised
because it's almost like in their minds,
they're wanting everything to go back
to exactly the way it was.
And then because it's not exactly
the way it was that again,
kind of leads them into
a tailspin of anxiety,
because then they're
not sure how to navigate
this new normal in a sense.
There's still even this people
that are in certain areas of the country
the masks aren't as prevalent,
then some people are feeling
really uncomfortable with that.
Some people might be more septal.
So how do you meet people individually
with those types of things to
kind of set, well, I guess,
realistic expectations in a way
that doesn't lead people
astray when they, again,
hit things that aren't what they expected.
- Know, I think it's to the
point where we just literally,
we asked the questions.
When we come in, we can't just start off,
like you said, as is, we have
to take a moment to pause
and say, listen, we need to
reset, we need to recalculate,
we need to recalibrate
this whole thing and say,
where are we at?
Just to the point who feels
with Madison, who doesn't?
Because now you can kind
of create certain groups.
You can say, this is what we're gonna do
to put you where you're comfortable.
But the thing is, if we don't ask,
we don't know if we make assumptions,
then we put people in categories
that probably won't be
to their best interest.
And Pastor, I apologize.
I thought you was about to say something,
I shouldn't need to cut
you off, 1000 apologies.
- No, no, no, it's everything
you're saying, I echo
because it's funny where
we're trying to regather
and we're coming back in,
the church is starting
to come back together.
Now some people chose to do it anyway,
but we, something that
Dr. Smith was saying,
meeting people where they're at.
And one thing we did is
'cause everybody is something,
it was mask, no mask, social
distance, no social...
People just didn't,
all they knew is they just
wanted to get back together,
but there was some people that didn't.
And so we had to take the assessment,
we had to put the survey
out and you would be amazed
at what some people were
saying on the survey.
And so we said, okay,
collectively, what we have to do
is show people that we're using wisdom.
We're not just gonna
do this thing blindly,
but we're gonna do this in stages
and we're gonna do it right.
So we got our doctors, in our house,
that they get paid a lot of
money to do what they do.
And they are doctors,
they're professionals,
they got all the alphabets behind the...
so that made us look good,
And we said, "What should we
do, what are you guys hearing?"
And began to ask them questions,
and they begin to lay it out
exactly what Dr. Smith said.
There are people that are
gonna be here mentally,
there are people that are scared
or people that are frightened,
or then you got the gung-ho
people that just don't care,
they're just ready to re-emerge
and get back to normal.
And so we've had to balance
that and meet people halfway
and say, okay, if you wanna wear a mask,
we're not gonna shun you about that,
do what's best for you and your family.
But if somebody over here chooses not to,
then that's up to them.
But just meeting people where they are
and not putting that extra
pressure or extra stress on them
to make them try to do
something or be something
that they're not ready to do or be
in this season of their life.
One thing I've learned a
long time ago, slow is fast,
and I would rather do
something the right way
than do something the wrong
way and then it blows up.
And so people are frustrated.
You guys should be meeting,
you're letting this happen.
And I'm like, no, no,
we'll come back together when it's right.
And then fortunately
it's starting to happen.
And so meeting people where
they are, listening to them,
being mindful of children, I
think a lot of times as adults,
we forget that, we forget where they are
and what they're dealing with.
And if we're going through it,
and then they probably going
through it twice as bad.
And so being able to stop
and say, but what about them?
You know, they're the priority right now.
So we have to make sure
that they're healthy,
that they're whole, that
they're being talked to
and loved and cared for,
just as much as we're trying to get it.
And so that was a big deal
for us is just saying,
we got to take care of our babies.
We can't be worrying
about like what we want,
but we need to be at
a pace where they are,
because this is just not normal for them.
It's just not going to
school and things like that.
So that was a big thing
for us and for our people,
but meeting people where they are
and not marginalizing them,
or making them feel less than
based off of their emotions
and their feelings or
their mental awareness
was very important.
- Yeah, that's so good and
it seems like a lot of ways
you are giving people space
and time to just process
and go through what was happening.
And so, I think, Dr. Smith,
you can probably speak to this as well,
but I think sometimes it's easy for us
to forget about that
with the children too,
because they're the way they
react is gonna be different
from the way the adults
react, as you mentioned.
And sometimes if we're not
keen to that or realizing that,
oh, so-and-so is not just acting out,
they're really just trying
to process everything
that's going on, they're
feeding off of the adults too,
and really just taking the
time to be attended to.
And Pastor Shino as you mentioned,
giving people time to kind of
walk through those pieces too.
'Cause I think sometimes there's
an inclination to go fast,
like you said too.
Just kind of plow through the emotions,
push it down and ignore it.
I mean, I've definitely seen people
doing that around anxiety
during the pandemic
or anxiety after it.
It's almost that people are saying,
well, this shouldn't be
as much of a struggle.
So they kind of minimize it, stuff it down
and it just keeps re popping up
and it just kind of cycles
and cycles and cycles.
And I'm curious with both of
you, even elaborating that,
how have you given people
space and time to process that,
are there specific ways
that you think it's
helpful in the healthy,
is it an awareness piece,
is it practical tips?
How have you approached that,
Dr. Smith's you wanna jump in?
Oh, no, I'm gonna switch back.
- No, I was just like,
oh, I was saying for me,
it was creating space
for our men to be men.
I think a lot of times, you're
looked at weak or whatever,
if you're losing it, you
know what I'm saying?
If you're really losing it.
And I recognize and realize
based off of what was
coming across my screen
guys were checking out.
You know, when I say checking out,
some brothers was like leaving,
like, I'm out of here, I'm gone.
And it was like, whoa, you
know, we have to address this.
And so creating spaces
where men could be men
and talk about what's really going on
being leaders in their homes
and it was a safe place.
It was safe, but bringing
in the right people,
so brought in a Dr. Suite to talk to them.
We brought in a Dr. Nii
Addy to talk to them.
We brought in a Dr. Schaefer,
men that could minister,
not just from the Word of God,
but also from a clinical
point of view as well,
meeting both the body and the
soul because men were broken,
for the first time real pressure,
they couldn't pull them
stress out of the bootstraps.
You know, you couldn't,
whatever faith through it,
you needed some real help.
And having guys being
able to come together
and say, man, this is
what's going on in my home.
This is what's going on on my job,
or this is what's going
on with my children.
And hearing everybody across
the board say, amen, amen.
That's what's happening in my house too.
How can we do this, how
can we navigate this?
And with that said,
what it did for the men,
what it made them realize
that they're not alone
and that they're not the
only ones going through it.
So it made them feel like,
hey man, I'm not losing
it and I'm not crazy.
And so it was really important for them
to be able to share that.
And I mean guys were
crying, guys were weeping,
and dudes were on the verge of the,
I'm just gonna be honest,
they were on the verge of divorce, man,
because they just, they
couldn't handle it.
The stress that was going on in the home,
the pressures of having to make
it happen at the workplace,
but not being able to go to
work and all those things.
And so man, being able
to create safe places
for guys to be, just
men to be men, to weep,
because we say it like this,
as the men go, so goes to society.
And I mean, I'm by no
means in my marginalizing
or putting down women
or anything like that.
But what I am saying is
the men are, you know,
they wanna come in and they
wanna provide and protect
and do all the things
that they are wired to do.
And for the first time,
it didn't feel like they could do that.
Things are being taken away from them
and it was this important for them
to be able to come into safe places,
to talk and discuss and
be edified and built up
and get real solutions to real problems.
- That's so good, Dr. Smith,
you wanna jump in as well?
- Yeah, you know, Pastor
Shino said the magic word,
you know, it's normalcy,
'cause everybody's
saying, oh, it's just me.
Once you get that idea,
okay, it's not just me,
this everybody's going
through it, guess what?
Now we can kind of come together.
It's like, I can get through this
because this is something
everybody is going through.
And so when we talk about that,
we also talked about like those stages
and Pastor Shino talked about
as far as elevating people.
When we talk about children,
you think about what
did they do in schools?
They went from virtual to hybrid
and then to like fall back in,
because what you gotta do
is slowly give a process
and a progress.
But what we have to remember is this,
'cause this is to your
original point, Dr. Addy,
children brains are not fully developed.
We know from neuroscience,
the brain does a fully develop
till you're between 25-28.
So that's the prefrontal lobe,
the executive functioning,
the problem solving, the impulse control.
So when we're talking
about younger people,
we can't expect them to think like adults.
So what we do have to do
is have to have an extra level of grace,
extra level of patience
extra level of understanding,
and we have to accommodate our rules.
So any school that has a 0% tolerance,
we're gonna have to relax on that,
we're going to have to flex on that.
Now, does that mean we
excuse bad behaviors?
No, but what we do is we
look at any type of behavior
that we might consider
to be bad, antisocial
that goes against the rule
as a learning experiment.
And we have to say,
how do we now make
these teachable moments?
How do we, instead of
punishing individuals,
how do we learn and we grow from it?
So now what we have to expect
is there are gonna be
individual situations
where if we can't express
ourselves verbally, what do we do?
We express ourselves physically.
So we also have to make sure
that we're creating an environment
that's conducive for safety so
we can minimize these things.
What we have to do is to be
able to see them in advance
so we can nip them in the
bud before they flourish.
And those are the things
that we don't want to come to fruition.
So I think the thing is,
how can we be proactive
in our plans to saying,
what can we predict
based on other societies?
I always laugh from a pop
culture, kind of tells my age,
but remember the story of life.
And when Martin Lawrence was
out looking for the first time,
and he'd like, what the world is going on?
What we have to do is give
people a chance to what?
Assimilate back into society slowly
so by doing those things.
So there has to be a shared
language between the schools,
between the community
and between the homes.
And hopefully some of those
bridges that was broken,
Pastor Shino talked about,
that personal, relationship, equity,
maybe this is a time where we
say, listen, we've been apart.
This is maybe the impetus for us to say,
we can't be a part now it is,
we have to put our egos aside
for the betterment of our children.
So how do the adults really become adults
and to create programs
that help our children
succeed on all types of levels,
not only academically and athletically,
but also socially and emotionally?
- Well, I love that the way
that everything that you both have said
is kind of cut across from
kids all the way up to adults
and creating those spaces,
I mean, just in terms of our expectations>
I think a lot is, again,
we haven't talked about
stigma a lot per se,
but it really hits on that.
Like the stigma that we applied
to the kids and say, okay,
if they're acting out as,
because of X, Y, and Z,
not because they're struggling to process.
Or the stigma with men that,
oh, if they're falling apart
is because there's
something wrong with them,
rather than giving the space
for people to come together and weep
and talk through stuff and processes
Pastor Shino was talking about.
So I think that's so important
in so many different ways.
And Dr. Smith, as you were mentioning too,
just all the aspects about our brains
and how we process those things.
I mean, definitely with
the kids with the time
that they need to
develop with their brains
and really understand those things
and how we can guide them
through it in that time.
And then for us as
adults, just the effects
that community has on our brains
and how it influences
certain peptides and oxytocin
and things like that,
that actually influence
those parts of brains
and give us those connections
and help us be healthy in a lot of ways.
So it's really encouraging
just to hear the ways
that you've both have
done that so practically,
I know that it's deeply
important to the communities.
And even with that pushback
that you both mentioned,
that comes at times, being
able to push through that
and really meet people where they are,
I think is so powerful
and it goes a long way.
I'm curious, as we're wrapping up too,
what gives both of you hope
as we're moving through,
'cause we've hit on a lot of the lows
and some of the hope
that comes in between,
but what's your sense of
hope for how we go forward
as a society from here.
And let me see who wants to jump in,
Pastor Shino you're
ready, so I didn't come...
- I'm gonna defer it to the Pastor.
- No, I mean, yes, that's
great answers Dr. Smith, man.
I was just like, man, he's got it.
He's got the word right there.
For me, what brings hope
it's showing me right now
what I'm seeing as things are opening up,
people genuinely have learned something,
is that we're better together.
And when I see it,
because people can't wait
to see each other again,
it used to be like, man,
I don't wanna see them,
I don't wanna hear, now it's like, man,
you see people running,
you see people connecting
and there's genuine conversations,
there's genuine when you
say, "How are you doing?"
You really mean it.
You know, it's not just
lip service anymore.
It's just like, man, how are you really?
You go down the list of your wife,
your children, or whatever.
Maybe you heard something
about their job or whatever,
and you know, did you get it back
or were furloughed or whatever?
So that brings hope to me
is that people actually wanna
gather, wanna be together.
And not just any people I've
seen different ethnicities,
crossing cultural and
spending time and just
friendships that were
not really that solid
are now really solid.
And so it's no longer just lip service,
but it's genuine, "Man, I missed you.
I missed by our friendship,
and I wanna make sure
that if anything was
said or done in the past,
let's make it right now."
So that that's really
bringing a lot of hope
that people really genuinely
have a concern for one another.
They really do.
- That's so good and that learning.
Yeah, it's encouraging to see
things that we took for granted before
that I think we just have a
different appreciation for.
Dr. Smith how about you?
- You know what?
I think I wanna end it
with, I was reading a book
called "The Soul of
America" by Jon Meacham.
And inside the book, he quoted Mark Twain.
He says, "History may not repeat itself,
but it sure does rhyme."
And when we think about this
once in a century pandemic
that we went through,
not only were we going through a pandemic,
as in before we were just ending
a World War, the first one,
you saw what happened to
our Japanese citizens,
we saw what was going on with the KKK
and the different things,
even with women's suffrage
and things of that nature.
And I look and I say,
wow, it seems like we're
in a repeat itself.
But also what I look back is I say,
I would much rather live
in 2019, 2020, 2021,
than 1919, 1920, 1921.
And so the question is for hope as to say,
even despite those same times
that it was very similar to to
what we're going through now,
our ancestors found a way
to not only overcome it,
but to make it better.
So we got there?
No, absolutely not.
But that's where the hope comes in.
Because what we say is
what will the generations
of tomorrow say about us?
And this is where I put
my hope in my creator,
I put my hope and my
fellow brothers and sisters
of humanity and say,
what are we going to do
to make it better for the next generation,
the next two generations that are coming.
And so that's when it's
incumbent upon us saying,
hey, you know what?
I have hope because in my hands
I help control some of this.
So what am I willing to do?
What am I willing to give?
And when I look at all
of the great peoples
throughout times of antiquity,
who we appreciate, who we respect,
is the Jesus of Nazareth,
people who are willing
to give their lives,
to Martin Luther Kings.
We look at the Muhammad Alis,
maybe I don't give my life,
but I give up what?
My freedom, I give up my career.
I give up certain things
so I can make a point
to make it better for all.
So what I challenged myself to do,
and hopefully that burners
off on others, like,
what am I willing to sacrifice?
What am I willing to
give to make it better
for the next generation?
But knowing I have some power over that,
gives me a feeling of hope.
It's like when you're driving a car,
I'd much rather be driving than
being in the passenger seat,
'Cause you got a little control.
And because I feel I have that control
and I know what's controlling me,
I feel a better hope for tomorrow.
And that's what I wanna try
to convey to all who I touch.
- Mm that's so good.
Definitely appreciate what
both of you share and the ways.
To be honest, that you're
doing that on this, you know,
in the work that you're doing already,
but just being in this
conversation today too.
'Cause I know folks who
are going to be listening
and the practical tips that
you've, you've laid out,
just the honesty that you've laid out,
I know that goes a long way,
just to bringing people
together in community.
And again, making things better
for those who are here with us now,
those who are coming after us.
And you know, I'm just
grateful to be honest
for both of you.
I know community is huge,
that's definitely come
through in this conversation.
And I think that there is
hope, we do have ways to go.
There are ways that we're
growing stronger as community.
I guess my hope is that
that continues as well,
that we can really hold onto that
and not forget in the moment.
That we don't forget everything
that you both mentioned
that we've learned after going
through things this year.
That we don't forget what we've learned
about some of the disparities there,
not that those weren't there before,
but for, I think for many people,
there's a new level of awareness.
And just what both of you
were mentioning about action,
where you wanted to kind
of take that action,
step in and get to a
better place as humanity
under one creator and
just have that wholeness
as a community and together.
So definitely appreciate
both of you being on here,
sharing your words of
wisdom with our listeners.
I know there's a lot that
I've learned from both of you.
I'm still, to be honest,
just soaking it all in,
'cause there's so many good
points that you both brought up.
So Pastor Shino, Dr. Smith,
thank you so much for being here.
It's been a great conversation.
Definitely appreciate both of you.
And I know this is gonna be
great for our listeners as well.
- Thanks for having me,
it's a pleasure to meet you,
Pastor Shino and Dr. to Addy.
That makes me hopeful,
knowing that it's great
man like you in the world
that influence so many other people.
So I'm looking forward to
what we can do going forward.
- Agree. Agree.
- Agree.
(gentle music)